hasta donde alcanza la vista varios
estanques de barro y mini lagos
artificiales un paisaje familiar en esta
región del este de camerún que tiene la
reputación de ser un eldorado
en esta mina a cielo abierto cientos de
mineros de oro desprotegidos en estas
aguas contaminadas por el mercurio entre
ellos hay docenas de niños y muchas
niñas algunos menores de cinco años
trabajo infantil a la vista de todos en
este sitio operado por una compañía
china no se nos permitirá grabar más o
entrevistar a estos jóvenes buscadores
de oro
no muy lejos de aquí está route una de
las jóvenes buscadores de oro de la zona
esta mañana la niña de 14 años no fue a
la escuela pasa sus días en este agujero
de 7 metros de profundidad
ya soy aquí viniste a lavar la grava
para encontrar la veta correcta de oro
ruth trabaja en colaboración con otro
adolescente que se está hundiendo en
esta oscura galería subterránea de
varios kilómetros de largo podría
colapsar en cualquier momento
una hora más tarde el adolescente sale
de allí con su recipiente lleno ya estoy
llegando hasta allí si estoy aquí te
estoy esperando
entonces el trabajo de root puede
comenzar horas para lavar la tierra y
conseguir ese residuo de oro el botín
del día para la joven buscador a que
nunca ha ido a la escuela nunca fui a la
escuela porque mis padres no pueden
pagarla es por eso que he estado
trabajando buscando oro desde que era
pequeña para mantener a mi familia soy
consciente de los peligros de la mina
como el gas que inhaló en esta cueva
donde podría haber un derrumbe en
cualquier momento también hay muchas
enfermedades como la sarna la longitud y
otras infecciones que pueden contraer de
esta agua sucia pero no tengo otra
opción un trabajo peligroso por un
sueldo de miseria hola señor bienvenida
a ruth veamos que trajiste
unas horas más tarde ruth viene a vender
su botín a uno de los muchos
coleccionistas clandestinos de oro de la
zona con su balanza electrónica evalúa
el precio a pagar a ruth trabajar con
niños no incomoda al traficante al
contrario
logrando más galleta a 9.000 el gramo se
compra normalmente a 33 37 o 46 dólares
pero a esos niños les damos 18 dólares
por gramo eso depende porque no están en
una posición de fuerza 2 preferimos
trabajar así en lugares ocultos porque
no podemos exponernos ya que el gobierno
y la ley prohíben que los niños hagan
este tipo de trabajo anual entre usd and
found y facebook a vela con 9 miligramos
de oro vendidos root se fue con un poco
más de dos dólares 30 a 60 por ciento
menos de lo que un adulto podría haber
negociado una mísera suma que lleva a
casa de sus padres al anochecer hija
cómo fue el día no muy bueno realmente
papá solo encontré muy poco oro los
padres de ruth son antiguos buscadores
de oro aquí el trabajo de la mina se
transmite de generación en generación
con lo que gana la hija la familia puede
sobrevivir incluso si el padre es
consciente de los riesgos
a veces se llega a casa con heridas y ni
hablemos de la malaria todos los días en
el agua hay mucho riesgo y fuera pero si
te quedas en el pueblo no puedes
encontrar nada a través del oro que ella
siempre lucha mamá su madre tuvo que
hacerlo yo también tuve que trabajar en
las minas
ahora estamos cansados y viejos
la fatiga tu salud el 10
en batury el 90 de los niños la mitad de
ellos niñas trabajan en las minas según
la ong a la que pertenecen estos dos
hombres eviten que los niños vayan a
buscar el oro durante el año escolar
tienen que enviarlos al colegio tomás y
juniors luchan desde hace varios años
para que los jóvenes mineros vuelvan a
las aulas su prioridad hacer que los
padres sean conscientes de la
importancia de la escuela los padres
prefieren enviar a las chicas jóvenes
enviar a los niños en edad escolar a las
minas que enviarlos a la escuela nuestro
deber como ong es venir a
sensibilizarlos para que dejen de
comportarse así y que asuman sus
responsabilidades porque la educación es
un derecho fundamental para los niños
unos pocos kilómetros más adelante la
campaña hace una parada en el patio de
esta escuela aquí la pedagogía se basa
en una escena teatral interpretada por
los escolares delante de sus padres
[Música]
este es el hombre que comenzó el
programa eric dejó la mina en 2014 ahora
es director de la escuela y busca
reeducar en masa a los jóvenes mineros
o contra la misma la mina no me ayudó a
crecer al contrario la mina me arruinó
trabajaba para pagar las deudas y para
pagar las cuentas del hospital entré en
la en la escuela normal para maestros de
educación general y semi entrenamiento y
volvió al pueblo para enseñar incentivo
a la comunidad educativa que envía a los
niños a la escuela los cep tony visual
en libro pule a un centenar de niños ya
se ha unido a la escuela pero miles más
siguen en las minas un peligro para su
educación en esta región que proporciona
casi 700 kilos de oro cada año